Холодний початок виборчого року для Володимира Путіна.
З новими силами російський президент бореться за четвертий термін.
Опитування свідчать - у нього хороші шанси на перемогу.
Але хто буде його конкурентом?
Павло Грудінін?
Він новачок у перегонах, але, згідно з кількома
опитуваннями, вже на другому місці після Путіна.
Грудінін - і прагматичний комуніст, і успішний підприємець.
Він має аграрний бізнес неподалік Москви.
Його частково популістичні ідеї подобаються багатьом виборцям.
Гроші в Росії є.  Коли купують величезні яхти,
водночас у нас не вистачає грошей на те, щоб
побудувати теплий туалет в школі.
Я вам можу сказати - гроші в Росії є.
Їх тільки треба повернути в державу і скерувати
на добробут наших громадян.
Грудінін критикує уряд – зокрема, на державних каналах.
Замикає трійку лідерів - Володимир Жириновський.
Це вже шості президентські перегони, на яких він балотується.
Правий популіст з Ліберально-демократичної партії
має репутацію шоумена.
Це - передвиборний ролик Жириновського на останніх президентських виборах.
Росія постає тут в образі ледачого віслюка,
якого треба штовхати вперед.
Іще один новачок перегонів - Kсенія Собчак.
Опитування дають їй кілька відсотків.
Девіз Собчак – ті, хто втомився від інших
кандидатів, має обирати її.
З гламурної дівчини та зірки телевізійного реаліті-шоу
Собчак перетворилася на відому опозиціонерку.
Вона критично ставиться до уряду та вважає
анексію Криму незаконною.
Я хочу іншу Росію - з найкращими науковцями,
найкращими людьми, які роблять свою справу,
найкращими інноваціями.
Європейську Росію. Для мене це дуже важливо,
тому що я бачу Росію як частину Європи.
Критики Собчак дорікають їй тим, що її
кандидатура узгоджена з Кремлем.
Свого часу її батько був союзником Путіна.
Ці три кандидати - найактивніші у президентських перегонах в Росії.
Проте навряд чи зможуть вплинути на результат.